harcèlement excision mariages forcés
violences physiques et sexuelles
combien sont les victimes femmes ou
hommes à périr sous les coups de leur
mari conjoints concubins ou partenaires
combien d'enfants victimes collatérales
aurait se marquer à vie
en 2010 huit cent trente femmes ces
hommes et 25 enfants tués directement
dans le cas des violences conjugales 76
femmes depuis le début de l'année au nom
de ses victimes
mettons fin aux postures aux clivages et
au discours aussi sur les violences
conjugales
nous vous demandons d'accepter nos
propositions qui sont prioritairement
généraliser le bracelet électronique et
le faire payer aux conjoints violents
organisés une justice spécialisée
conserver une trace des plaintes et des
mains courantes même quand les femmes
sous emprise se rétracte cesser de
considérer le conjoint violent comme un
bon parent et protéger les enfants en
les éloignant créer un fichier national
des personnes violentes fournir un
extrait de casier judiciaire lors d'un
mariage développer des hébergements
notamment d'urgence et bien d'autres
mesures qui figurent dans nos
propositions dans l'agglomération
grenobloise depuis plusieurs semaines
des actes communautaires viennent chaque
jour fracturé un peu plus notre contrat
républicain
à deux reprises des femmes militantes
qui on offre la volonté d'aller contre
les interdits ont fait le choix de
défier l'autorité publique et sont venus
se baigner en burkini dans les piscines
municipales sur les pourtant interdit
par les règlements intérieurs
dans le même temps nous avons appris
qu'une école salafistes que le ministre
de l'éducation nationale a qualifié d'
aspiré par les idéologies radicales est
toujours ouverte
elle devait pourtant fermé mais cette
décision est suspendue dans l'attenté
d'un procès qui ne se déroulera pas
avant novembre
une telle situation illustre une seule
et même orientation qu'il faut dénoncer
haut et fort la fracturation
communautaire de notre société conjuguée
à l'offensive une forme d'agression
identitaire face à de tels actes
si notre pacte républicain qui chaque
jour s'abîme un peu plus notre système
de santé est dans un état critique et
bien des personnels sont au bord du burn
out je veux rendre hommage à tous ces
professionnels médecins infirmiers aides
soignants urgentistes ces femmes et ces
hommes qui permet à la france de
disposer d'un système de santé des plus
performants
comment dans nos territoires et au plus
près des habitants l'action de l'état
pourrait être davantage face et
facilitatrice guidés par le bon sens et
permettre à la fois l'innovation
l'expérimentation et la mise en oeuvre
de solutions efficaces contre les
déserts médicaux en avril 2019
dans son programme national de réforme
le gouvernement se féliciter des
résultats obtenus les transformations
issue d'appel 2022 vont notamment se
traduire par des baisses du nombre
d'emplois publics déjà mises en oeuvre
par les lois de finances pour 2018 et
on aurait aimé y croire malheureusement
ni la cour des comptes
ni la commission européenne ne partage
votre auto satisfaction
[Musique]